[Music]
legend has it that one day a new king
will come
[Music]
who will use the power of the Trident
report Atlantis back together one can is
the exact spot that Volkl give me my
first woman lesson not even close
you have to forget all the teaching of
the surface world now go deeper one
covering your Atlantean instincts he
spent his entire life paint
then him to be the best
my parents made me what I am
I am the protector of the deep
in this Trident resides the power of
Atlantis in the wrong hands it would
bring destruction in the hands of the
trelaina it would unite above and below
the time has come for mantis to rise
again
mas talkin about you proposed me mm by
retrieving this are yahwah's not like
this one you don't the war is coming to
the surface whether you like it or not
mother always knew you were special
you believe
you'd be the one to night out - whoa
he's always had a key
now I need something more
what could be greater than a king
a human
[Music]
[Music]